it's now been over a year since apple
revealed the m1 imac at their spring
event it has been extremely useful to us
in our office since our main editor
angelic has been editing basically every
single video that you've seen come up on
our channel over the past year with the
24 inch imac but now we've recently
started to get a flood of leaks for the
upcoming m2 max that we're all expecting
to get sometime this year and
unfortunately the 24 inch imac has been
missing from those leaks but over the
past few days we finally got some major
leak and rumor confirmation of what all
of us feared it looks like there will be
no 24 inch m2 imac and apple is instead
going to be holding off until the m3
chip is ready to update this imac again
so in this video i'm going to be going
through all of those leaks and putting
all the little puzzle pieces together to
try to find out why apple would do this
as well as which features we should
expect and how much performance we
should expect as well and finally i'm
gonna answer a couple of the most
important questions when is it expected
to actually launch and should you wait
for it compared to just buying the
current m1 imac right now and before i
get into all those leaks i've got to
share our experience with the 24 inch m1
imac over the past year like i said
before our editor angelica has been
using it full time to edit almost all of
our youtube videos and she's been
absolutely loving it and that's pretty
impressive because she used to edit on a
27-inch imac from 2020 which was almost
two times more expensive than this new
m1 imac in fact she likes it so much
that she even said that she wishes she
had this imac at her house and she said
she's gotten used to the smaller display
size and has no issues at all and she
especially loves how much more snappy
the m1 chip is compared to the old intel
chips so with all that said it should
give us some perspective in terms of the
future 24 inch imac update because if
this current m1 model can already
satisfy the editing needs of a youtube
channel like ours which tries to post 6
videos per week it should be enough for
the vast majority of people but now
let's finally jump into the leaks and
rumors with a huge report from mark
german who was the most reliable apple
analyst out there this past sunday he
talked about what we should expect for
the next upcoming max including a bunch
of m2 based macs like the macbook air
the mac mini macbook pros and even the
mac pro but in terms of the imac he said
that he heard about an m3 version of
that desktop being already in the works
though he imagines it won't launch until
the end of next year at the earliest and
this leak is actually a huge deal
because it perfectly matches up to
information from another source leaks
apple pro he says that his sources
expect a bunch of m3 macs coming late
2023 including a new m3 mac mini a
macbook air and a macbook pro and that
is actually exactly when i'm personally
expecting the very first m3 max to
launch late 2023 and the reason for that
is because the m3 chip is rumored to be
based on tsmc's three nanometer chip
process and digi times recently reported
that tsmc will begin production of three
nanometer chips in the last quarter of
2022 with apple actually launching three
nanometer base products in 2023
like the m3 chip and the a17 chip for
iphones but even before that we were
getting reports back in november about
three nanometer mac and iphone chips
coming as soon as 2023 and we recently
got another report from digitimes that
tsmc is on track to begin three
nanometer chip production in the second
half of this year but as far as the m3
imac leaks apple pro actually said that
it'll launch in early 2024
a few months after the first m3 max
launch in the fall quarter of 2023 and
that actually makes perfect sense to me
because that's exactly what apple did
with the first m1 max they launched
three of them in november of 2020 and
then they waited about half a year until
launching the m1 imac so i think there's
a good chance they're going to be doing
that again but now let's finally answer
the big question why in the world would
apple skip the m2 imac and wait that
long until refreshing it again with the
m3 chip well i think the main reason is
because almost every m2 mac is expected
to come with a total redesign except the
imac for example we're expecting a full
redesign for the m2 mac mini becoming a
lot thinner than before showing how
powerful apple silicon truly is
then we also have the m2 macbook air
which will also be getting a full
redesign with a new thin chassis new
color options mac save 3 and a new
display with white bezels and probably a
notch and the only other machine left
would be the base m2 macbook pro which
is by far the most confusing because
apparently this one is not going to be
getting a full redesign but who knows
maybe it'll take on the 14-inch macbook
pro redesign we really don't know just
yet but the point that i'm making is
that what if the m2 chip isn't going to
be enough of a deal by itself to justify
a new product refresh so apple is
combining the m2 chip with a redesign to
make the new m2 max look like a great
upgrade but now let's move our focus
over to the 24 inch imac and why apple
would skip the m2 chip refresh and wait
for the m3 chat well of course this is
the only m1 mac that actually received a
full redesign last year and since it
already has its redesign what if giving
it the m2 chip wouldn't be enough of an
upgrade to make it worth it in the eyes
of consumers and especially youtubers
who are going to be reviewing it like us
and i can tell you right now the m2 chip
alone isn't going to be enough to make
it worth upgrading from the m1 24 inch
imac to a new m2 model unless apple
packs in a bunch of other new features
and that's because i honestly don't
think the m2 chip is going to be that
big of an upgrade seeing as i still
believe it's going to be slower than the
14 inch macbook pros m1 pro chip so if
you're wondering how the m2 chip will
compare here is a chart of the single
core performance considering two
different scenarios with the m2 chip
based on either the a15 or future a16
chip cores and as you can see the single
core performance is where you'll see the
biggest advantage for things like web
browsing however in terms of multi-core
the performance is still lacking
compared to the m1 pro chip and that's
mainly because the m2 is expected to
keep the same 8 core cpu layout as the
m1 already has 4 efficiency cores and 4
performance cores now in terms of
graphics performance that's where we'll
likely see a nice boost because the
cores will not only be getting faster
but apple will be adding two more gpu
cores to the m2 chip but yet again we're
still expecting the graphics performance
to also lag behind the m1 pro chip so
with that said it kind of makes sense
why apple would wait for the m3 chip
because that would finally be a big
enough performance and feature jump to
make it worth upgrading to that new m3
24 inch imac because i fully believe
that the m3 chip will outperform the m1
pro in every way and the reason i
believe this is because the m3 chip is
reportedly going to be based on tsmc's
brand new three nanometer technology
which should have a pretty huge leap
over the current 5 nanometer technology
which is used in the m1 chip the a15
chip and likely the new a16 chip going
into the upcoming iphone 14 models which
would technically be called tsmc's n4p
process which makes it sound like four
nanometer but in reality tsmc themselves
confirmed that it's actually five
nanometer plus plus plus so going from
that to true three nanometer will be a
huge jump in performance per watt and it
would allow the m3 chip to get a lot
more powerful without requiring better
cooling solutions now on top of that
leaks apple pro gave us some exclusive
information concerning the chip layout
we should be expecting for the m3 chip
apparently apple has two prototypes of
the m3 one with an 8 core cpu which is
unchanged from the m1 and m2 and then
the other prototype has a 10 core cpu
adding two more performance cores and
this actually matches up to my own
personal expectations because it makes
sense for apple to add more cores as
they switch to better processed nodes
from tsmc because the cores have
improved performance per watt allowing
them to run cooler than before so apple
can balance it out by adding more chorus
now leex apple pro actually suggests
that apple could use both prototypes
with the lower end 8 core cpu version
going into the macbook air and the 10
core going into the base macbook pro
finally making a difference in
performance between both macs and in my
opinion i fully expect both of these
prototype m3 chips to outperform the
current m1 pro chip because of the three
nanometer enhancements and that's
exactly why i think apple is waiting
until the m3 chip is ready to refresh
the imac again especially if apple
actually adds face id to the imac which
they considered doing for the m1 imac
but they ended up holding off so with
all that said i think the m3 imac is
gonna be a great upgrade but because it
might not launch until 2024
i think most people should honestly just
buy the current m1 imac right now or
wait for the new m2 max coming later
this year now if you disagree with me go
ahead and let me know down in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
the video go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and definitely check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]